what we have here are pictures of
running pigs and we could try to figure
out how many running pigs there are by
just counting the pigs but we're going
to start building some new muscles and
this muscle is going to involve hey if
we group the pigs into equal groupings
can that help us figure out how many
pigs there are and you can see that I
have groupings of seven each of these
groups are seven running pigs so how
many total groups do I have well I have
one two three groups of seven running
pigs each three equal groups so if I
said what's the total number of running
pigs that I'm dealing with well I have
three sevens three groups of seven and
so that's the same thing as 7 plus seven
plus seven and if you wanted to figure
out what that is you could skip count if
we skip count by seven we go 7 then 14
then 21 and so three sevens which is
seven plus seven plus seven is
twenty-one so there's twenty-one pigs
here and you can verify on your own that
if you count this you will indeed see
twenty-one pigs let's do another example
so here I'm looking at a picture of a
bunch of blue seals not something that
you are likely to see in the wild and
these blue seals have once again been
grouped let's see how many groups there
are there one two three four five six
seven groups and how many are in each
group well we could see that they're all
groups of 1 2 3 4 5 they're equal groups
so what are we dealing with well we're
dealing with seven groups of five so I
could write seven groups of five I could
write seven fives
I could write 5 plus 5 Plus 5 Plus 5
Plus 5 Plus 5 plus 5 so that is 7 fives
there and if I wanted to figure out
where that is I could skip count I could
skip count 7 5 so that would be 5 10 15
20 25 30 35 so if I were to have all
these fives up 5 Plus 5 is 10
another five you get to 15 out of their
five 20 add another five twenty-five as
another five thirty add another five
thirty five which is exactly what you
see there so we're starting to see that
sometimes grouping things can help us
appreciate how many things there are
there and I know what some of y'all are
thinking well hey couldn't I just count
things well you could but what if you
had a hundred groups of five well then
it'd take a little bit more time to
count but the techniques that we're
building will help you one day be able
to think about those things quite easily